let's be honest nobody enjoys handing
over money to the state in Germany even
the attempt to evade taxes is legally
prohibited but people are remarkably
inventive in their attempts to hide
money from tax authorities and they get
a lot of help more than 50 countries
around the world often tropical island
nations are considered tax havens
thousands of billions are held in
accounts there
it's a simple procedure anyone can start
an offshore company or create a trust in
a foreign country it's perfectly legal
and just like that the money's gone
almost untraceable nine for us experts
the fact that these loopholes exist is
completely normal everyone has known
about them for years become device Geeta
what's different says fiscal lawyer
Martin wolf is that tax evaders data is
no longer automatically secure the
internet he says is full of ads offering
to help people start offshore companies
some of them are legitimate others are
not but for someone trying to hide
several million euros from his home tax
authorities the risks involved could
well be worth taking that's on my mind
there are two special things about
offshore companies one is that it's very
easy to start or buy a company and
secondly the most important factor
nobody can find out who is behind it
when this secrecy can be used for
different ends Connie insufficient
inspect my hands it's
but as recent investigations have
uncovered banking confidentiality in
small Pacific Islands or big cities like
Singapore is usually used to evade
paying taxes elsewhere the British
Virgin Islands for instance have 474
thousand registered companies and only
thirty-two thousand inhabitants most
explosively there have been suggestions
that major banks including Deutsche Bank
have been involved in tax evasion
Deutsche Bank denies any wrongdoing but
unabashedly advertises business deals in
tax havens like Mauritius in the school
to have unless and if there's to be a
change in culture we need a cultural
revolution with regard to banks it's
obvious that things can't go on like
this governments are running out of
money because taxes aren't being paid
instead companies are being moved to the
same places that dictators used to hide
their riches this practice must be
stopped something with decimals that's
our lagunitas [ __ ] sadly it's a common
practice for people to dodge taxes while
national debts are exploding in Germany
alone tax evasion cost the state an
estimated 100 billion euros a year
imageview ebay taxes you're cheating the
rest of society Holomisa knocked in my
honest taxpayers have to make up and
plug the resulting holes with our tax
money it's cheating the rest of society
when some people live off the others who
pay the taxes joy exile any will cool
Appeals stop the illicit flow of money
across national borders that's very
unlikely what's needed our transparency
and clear international regulations
without them billions of euros will
continue to simply disappear
you